hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar multiplex bacterial pcr in
bronchio alveolar lavage bal does it
impact inappropriate antibiotic use
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by opt-gen
to learn more visit opgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
diana stoltz professor of respiratory
medicine and leading physician at the
university hospital basel university of
basel switzerland professor stoltz you
may now begin your presentation
hello and welcome to this webinar
looking at multiplex bacterial pcr in
the bronchoalveolar lavage does it
impact inappropriate antibiotic use
i'm professor diana stoze i'm located at
the university hospital basel in
switzerland and actually transitioning
uh to the university hospital in
freiburg in germany and i'm very happy
to be with you today i'm a pulmonary
physician
i treat um adult patients and
we've been looking at this methodology
since a few years now so i'm very happy
to share with you some views on
multiplex bacterial pcr in the
bronchoalveolar lavage
you find in this slide my conflicts of
interest
i've been supported by several companies
and this specific study has been
supported
by
curators
by an
unrestricted grant
and it's an investigator initiated and
driven study
so um what i would like to do with you
in the next
25-30 minutes or so is to look at
the challenges that we encounter every
day to diagnose
lower respiratory tract infections
particularly from the etiological point
of view
then we would compare
upper and lower respiratory respiratory
tract samples in terms of it's their
diagnostic value
look at some data on molecular
diagnostics and lower respiratory
extracting faction and then i would like
to present to you some of the latest
results we had also presented last week
at the european respiratory society
conference i don't know if you attended
but
this was selected as a late breaking
abstract reporting data on a very recent
randomized control trial we just
finished
so i'll start by stating that
the
current guidelines looking at commuted
acquired
pneumonia of from the
american thoracic society really
highlights the importance of the
etiological diagnosis of infection and
they say
that gram stain and culture is
recommended particularly in patients
hospitalized for severe cat and those
with strong risk factors for mrsa and
pseudomonas aeruginosa so these risk
factors are familiar to you our previous
infection with the parental use of
antibiotics in the last three months um
and this should be
looked for because these patients are at
risk for negative roads and um also
patients
have to be intubated they strongly
recommend to obtain lower respiratory
tract samples for um examination
so
although this is recognized as a really
uh
need it's also recognized that we are
not there yet so we do need more
research in this area because we need to
develop
tools that are rapid cost effective
sensitive and specific to diagnostic to
for the
this diagnostic test to identify which
are actually organisms that are causing
the infection so that we can really
treat in a very effective way and i
believe i will be able to share with you
some data that will convince you that
actually we do have already some of
these tools
we know that the etiological diagnosis
of lower respiratory tract infections is
a challenge because
it is
the most important thing for to define
the prognosis of these patients if we
are able to detect very earlier on the
course of the infection which pathogen
is causing the infection will be able to
treat this patient accordingly and the
prognosis will be better so we need to
initiate antibiotics at an early stage
knowing what we are treating not giving
too many antibiotics to broad spectrum
antibiotics because of resistance and
causes and side effects but we need to
be right to treat the organism that is
causing pneumonia and this is really a
challenge
because conventional microbiology is a
really questionable gold standard to
determine the presence of infection we
have a really very very low sensitivity
it goes down to 20
in some studies particularly if patients
are already treated with antibiotics
this decreases the sensitivity of the
method and the other problem is we have
to be very patient um we have to wait
two to three days
until we get uh information back from
the lab telling us whether the patients
have
actually a positive culture or not and
only then we can decide how to proceed
with the antibiotics so it's really not
ideal and i don't think we can call
conventional microbiology the gold
standard um currently to
establish the uh etiology of infection
and
even if we combined several
tests and this large study published a
few years ago in the new england had
reported that if you apply conventional
microbiology plus a pcare a pcr from the
upper respiratory tract for viruses
you still you will be able to detect the
theology of infection in only about 40
percent of these patients so in this
study
nasopharyngeal and oropharyngeal swaps
for viruses have been used they also use
blood cultures urinary
antigen sputum and pleural
uh in a fair in very few patients the
bronchovirus lavage and in only 40
percent uh the etiological diagnosis
could be made
in this study they found around 30
viruses and 14
bacteria in patients presenting with
respiratory symptoms of the lower airway
so um do we really need low respiratory
tract specimens we've been learning with
the covid pandemic unfortunately that
pcr for virus is very effective
but that nasopharyngeal swaps might be
actually enough in some patients and i
do believe they are very helpful but
still if we look um carefully we do
learn that um
respiratory samples from the lower
respiratory tract are of special value
particularly in some
in in some patient population
so uh in patients that are
immunocompromised we really may consider
to go
for sampling and the lower respiratory
tract because in these patients we might
have different co-infections and we have
found out that for example the recovery
of viral pcr is two times higher in a
lower respiratory tract specimens as
compared to patients um
to nasopharyngeal swabs in patients with
severe caps so you have a two times
higher chance to make a diagnosis if you
use samples from the lower respiratory
tract
we also learned that endotracheal
aspirates are more sensitive
that
for example no stroke swaps if we're
looking for influenza and
that the concordance between
samples from the upper and lower
respiratory tract is far from 100
percent it can be as low as 77
which is significant particularly if
your treatment strategy is it will be
going will be based on results of this
test
some other studies have talked even
about our 40 discrepancy
depending on which
respiratory agent we are looking here so
we've learned a lot from
viral pcr and
in some patients populations it's
probably not the best idea to stop
the examination just after having
a result of the nasopharyngeal swabs
if you have
the feeling the patient has an infection
so um we do know that
um some panels for viral and a typical
bacteria
are already established and
there is some with somehow lagging
behind when we talk about molecular
essays for
bacterial
agents
there are not so
much data out there looking at their
usefulness but this would be important
because if we know which is the bacteria
causing the disease if we know what
we're treating here we might be able to
target antibiotic de-escalation and in
this way protect the patients from side
effects
costs and also the development of
resistance so we do need to improve our
um diagnostic
eo here and i do believe that the
molecular diagnostic is the way to go
so
is it really important does it matter
um i do think it does because if we look
at the outcomes they are quite different
depending on whether you found a
bacteria or virus
and
the this interesting study suggests that
if you find a combination of
several agents causing infection in this
case and pneumonia
and
looking at survival
and need for intensive care
hospitalization you see that there is a
significant uh difference and if we look
at the
factors that influence hospital survival
we see that next to serum procalcitonin
we also see that the presence of a mixed
viral and bacterial infection will
indeed influence the chance that you
have to leave intensive care in the
hospital alive so i do think it matters
to know what the patient has it can help
us to improve treatment
and this is particularly the case again
in
the group of patients with severe
disease i don't think it makes
much sense to
go and try and find out what young
patients that are doing fine outside the
hospital with mild symptoms have
probably their empiric antibiotic
therapy is just fine but with a look at
severe disease and you see on the right
hand side the criteria defining severe
infections if you cap and those that are
immunocompromised and this is a large
group of patients nowadays
those those patients really benefit from
um
from etiological diagnosis patients with
with hematological diseases that develop
pulmonary infiltrates because of
infections and non-infections cause and
this patient population pneumonia is
really a killer and um if we don't know
we are treating we're going to have
difficulties here
there are some studies suggesting that
if you use micro biology conventional
microbiology alone there is a very low
diagnostic ill also here 26 percent and
here we have to consider that because
you found a bacteria or virus it doesn't
mean that nothing else is present so
patients might have multiple etiologies
uh with nemesis scarini for example
combined with something else and this is
quite relevant for the therapy so the
therapeutic consequences are immediate
and uh the treatment changes or
adaptations might be life-saving
so
i think you agree with me that better
diagnostic is key here and that we need
tests that are robust to diagnose
infections that provide us information
about susceptibility to antimicrobial
agents that are easy to perform that are
rapids that we can
provide information to the physician as
soon as possible and
we should question our so-called goat
standard with the conventional
microbiology
and i think um we've seen some mountain
data on the literature looking at this
test i selected some studies to share
with you this one looked at a multiple
multiplex bacterial pcr
in bell in children and they've seen
that
in this
79 children you found more pathogens
in the molecular testing than in culture
and this was a big difference 83
versus 31
and the rate of detection was even
higher in
patients that were
immunocompromised and in those that
received antibiotics so patients that
were on antibiotics the chance to find
the pathogen of a particular disease was
eight times higher if you use molecular
diagnostic instead of conventional
microbiology
and um
so
the sensitivity varies across the
studies but
i think we can say that most of them
support a higher sensitivity of
molecular tests and um also
some of the tests for example the
universal uh offers you uh the
opportunity to look to look at
resistance genes that will tell you
whether some
genes are present that will predict um
insensitivity to certain
antibiotic therapy
so this other study looked at 65
patients with suspicion of pneumonia
intensive care and also here the
pathogen identification rate was much
higher
with
pcr as compared to a conventional
microbiology and
here there was no difference in the
sensitivity depending on previous use of
antibiotic therapy but they tried to
quantify the impact
of molecular tests on management and
they came
to the conclusion that if
they
would use the results of molecular
intestines to decide
they would change antibiotics in up to
20 percent of this patient so
in a group of patients these
diagnostic tests really have a direct
influence in the treatment
what is important to note is as compared
to what we are used to see with culture
and for which we get a number like 10 in
the third or 10 in the fourth or ten in
the sixth potency for most molecular
tests including univero we will have a
signal that will be either positive or
negative
and for only very for example we know
that this for this signal to turn
positive uh you have to have at least 10
to the fourth if we look at the
bacterial count so the typical
bacterial count we have to consider a
culture positive is also applied to
decide whether universe test is to be
considered positive or negative
and
this is important because
as you know if we believe at the higher
sensitivity of molecular testing for the
diagnosis
there might be a question of culture
detecting uh organisms but is this now
in the molecular testing is this a
colonization or is this really infection
so for a lower amount of organisms
from pathogens that are not necessarily
pathogenic
then perhaps there is the question is
this really enough bacteria that will be
explaining why the patient is clinically
sick or is just a colonization and i
think it's uh reassuring to hear that
based on the cut-off sets
set for example for the universe test we
can
make sure that at least 10 in the fourth
potency
will be present so that we can call this
past positive
so uh we thought we talked also about
the the use of bacterial resistant genes
and this study has looked at this as
well
and
looked also at the adaptation of
antibiotic to
microbiology and i think it's
interesting to see
that it would be possible to be adapted
according to microbiology results in 50
of the cases
but in half of these cases you would be
able to change therapy to improve
therapy already earlier if you would
have access to the
pcr results
so um
so far to make a conclusion or to put
together what we know about the
resistance genes and um how to deal with
them i think we still don't have enough
data to say we do not need conventional
microbiology we don't need resistance
testing in a conventional way as we know
a resistance testing but i think there
is a growing knowledge in this um in
this field and we definitely have to
look uh for that we know this from the
gene expert for example for tuberculosis
it's very helpful and fast to help us
decide on how to proceed
so uh coming out to the
uh hospitalized pneumonia panel uh it's
a panel known in the us as the
al or lrt so a low respiratory tract
panel and it's fda cleared so it can be
used in patients with respiratory tract
infections
it could be cap hep or vap
that's what we studied in the last few
years in different patient populations
and i will be sharing with you this
result
and as you see here uh with this test
you have a panel of
21 bacteria that you'll be able to
either diagnose or exclude
with um
with this test but you also get this
resistance genes and there are 17 genes
that are examined in this panel and you
see here uh the mutation but also the uh
the gene that you have but also the the
which um
antibiotic will be affected for which
antibiotic you develop resistance if you
are
able to detect this gene so i i do
believe we need more data on this but
it's really reassuring to see that uh
with one past in a very short period of
time uh of a few hours you were able to
get results on the presence or absence
of the certain microorganisms and and at
the same time to get information about
the presence of resistance uh genes or
genes associated with resistance to the
commonly used antibiotics
and uh the first paper we have published
uh in chest
now um a few years ago i looked at the
diagnostic value of this method in the
broncoville lavage in a large population
of over 500 patients that were
heavily immunosuppressed
so um those are people that underwent
stem cell transplantation solid or
solid organ transplantation so really
most of them heavily immune suppressed
uh the half of them had a new filtrate
and almost 70 percent were on
antibiotics at the time of bronchoscopy
and we compared the results of this
universe pcr to conventional
microbiology
but also not only cultured uh but rather
also
the all analysis needed to differentiate
and to detect a typical microorganisms
fungi a multiplex vital pcr for 18
viruses and we confirmed the results of
this study by using a third diagnostic
method the rna 16s
so
you see here you can see here in these
three graphs that show the percentage of
positive bacteriology
according to the hospitalization time
before bal so on the left side you have
patients that have been hospitalized
before bal uh one day
in the middle they have been in the
hospital before three days before they
underwent bal and on the right side
seven days was the mean duration of
hospitalization before we perform bal
and you see that at every time point one
day three days and seven days
um in all patient groups so those with
and without antibiotics those with and
without infiltrates and those with the
combination infiltrates and antibiotics
the percentage the recovery
of a positive bacteriology was higher in
the group if you used multiplex pcr so
the universal panel uh here depicted in
foxy as compared to conventional
microbiology here depicted in this
bluish color so to every time point you
you diagnose more bacteria you have a
higher sensitivity if
you use a pcr test and
we try to find out what is really the
diagnostic yield of multiplex pci in the
bal looking at different constellations
because as i told you
i don't believe that conventional
microbiology is a very good
uh reference standard it's called the
gold standard but it's probably more um
silver standing as uh silver um standing
or so also and here we have uh looked at
patients with and without antibiotics uh
with positive or negative results of the
grand staining and those with and
without infiltrate and you see that
depending at what you take as the
reference standard you're going to have
a different sensitivity and specificity
so if we take the clinical diagnosis as
gold standard
we have a sensitivity
of 31
and a specificity of 91
this is really hard isn't it because the
clinical standard is also very uh poor
reference tended to define whether
bacteria bacteria is present or not uh
just for reference for the conventional
methods uh the sensitivity was 22
percent in specificity uh 98 percent so
the sensitivity was even lower
as compare
if you take the clinical diagnosis as a
gold standard for the conventional
methods as compared to the pcr
and what we've seen in this study is
that the sensitivity and the positive
likelihood freighter was higher in um if
we looked at a ground negative pathogens
so the the
correctness test was more sensitive and
had a higher positive likelihood ratio
to detect grand negative pathogens as
compared to the grand positive pathogens
so um we went on and
designed another investigative initiated
and driven study
looking at uh how this um panel how the
universe panel can really
influence or improve the clinical
outcomes in patients with suspected lrta
it was uh quad experimental pragmatic
study uh that included all patients that
underwent uh bronchoviola lavage for
suspicion of infection during 12 months
in our center
and
as again in
in one group of patients based on a
random two to one week
schedule
we had only the conventional
microbiology performed
or the conventional microbiology
performed plus the universal panel so
two weeks we had both examinations
one week we had only the conventional
microbiology so two weeks on one week
off
and then
results of the pcr test of the universal
pcr test were provided within four
hours after uh bronco viola lavage
but we didn't offer any kind of
support or guidance to the attending
physician on that so they got the
results
and
as they got the results as well from the
microbiology and they were
supposed to act as according to the
guidelines to decrease antibiotics to
stop antibiotics
according to what they've learned and we
looked at the primary outcome which was
the use of antibacterial therapy
antibiotic therapy within 30 days after
bronchoscopy so we had a group that had
both examinations and one group that had
only the conventional microbiology
we didn't provide any guidance
physicians had access to the pcr results
in one of these groups and we looked at
what happened after 30 days
and this was quite interesting we had
over 600 of
patients half of them immunocompromised
and
about the half were on antibiotics
[Music]
after
bronchos available
the other group had already before
been treated with antibiotics they
received antibiotics for 11 days
mortality was around 5
so it was a
population with a relevant disease and
we've seen that
the universe panel has detected bacteria
much more commonly than
conventional culture so there were 50
percent more bacteria detected using the
molecular test as compared to
conventional
culture but interestingly if we look at
the length of
antibiotic use
the number of antibiotics prescribed
and the length of hospital stay there
was no difference between these two
groups okay perhaps it tended to be a
bit shorter the use of antibiotics in
the uh in the group that had also pcr
results but this was not statistical
significance so
it was a bit uh disappointing to see
that although
we found more bacteria and we knew what
we were treating
it didn't really make a big
difference because people were didn't
change the antibiotics or they decreased
they stopped a bit earlier but not
as much as we would expect
so we thought why is that and uh we came
to the next study which um
is the new data i would like to
discuss with you today
that was around
the fact that we know that
antibiotic stewardship is quite a
challenging issue isn't it we know that
we feel uncomfortable in stopping
antibiotics if we do not know what is
going on
but
we need in this case an objective
measure of infection and we need to know
what is going on so the question in this
study was
if we combine
the result of the multiplex bacterial
pcr
with
a recommendation based on this result to
the physicians can we then
improve the treatment can we decrease
the use of inappropriate antibiotic
therapy in these patients
so this is a big question isn't it this
is the question can we really influence
therapy can we decrease the use of
inappropriate antibiotic therapy by
providing people results of a molecular
diagnostic test
copped
with or together with and bept in with
uh the uh our recommendation telling
them exactly what to do so if we found
this bacterium that's what you have to
do with the antibiotic therapy and
that's the question we wanted to
answer in this study
so um what we did here was again an
investigator initiated and driven
randomized controlled multi-center trial
our primary endpoint was the duration of
inappropriate antibiotic therapy
and we focus on adult patients with
suspicion of
and a clinical indication for
bronchoscopy and they also have to have
a risk for infection with grand negative
bacteria so we were focusing on the
sickest group of patients this patient
group that we've learned
from the recent
cap guidelines should be treated with
the ground negative coverage
this is a group of patients that have
risk factors as we've discussed before
and this is the group of patients that
we were focusing here taking benefit
from the fact that the universal panel
seemed to be particularly
helpful in detecting ground negative
roads
we excluded everybody that was notopanic
with sevilla ghd
pregnant women and you see on the left
side of the slide
the study design we have screened 740
patients
from those 217 were illegible and from
this 208 that
could be randomized we had 100 that been
allocated to the intervention group and
108 that have been allocated to the
control group
so what does it mean
the intervention group was the group of
patients that received bronchoscopy and
got
on top of the microbiological
conventional diagnosis a determination
of the presence of bacteria using the
univarial panel
and the control group
received bronchoscopy and have the
bronchovirus
analyzed solely by conventional
microbiology examination so that was the
design of the study within four hours
after bronchoscopy we could share with
the attending physician results of the
pcr of the bal
and tell them we found ground negative
roads
that's the way we would adapt the
antibiotic therapy or
we didn't find any
ground negative roads
and it's important to um to make sure
that
we understand that we didn't recommend
stopping our therapy but we recommend
de-escalating from usually uh pip
wrestling tesla back to for example
amoxicillin covalent acid
so uh those are the patient
characteristics in this group
those were uh patients around 65 year
old and you see that they had several
comorbidities uh immunosuppression again
present
in around 50 percent of the cases
with lots of respiratory symptoms an
increase in cfp to 140 so quite
high in fact
in fact
signs in the lab and also prococetonin
of 0.68
and
a psi score of 32.
around 70 of the patients were on
antibiotics at the time of bronchoscopy
for around 34 hours
and we have looked at almost 400
different antibiotic regimens that they
were receiving
so to the primary endpoint of the study
uh that's this was the duration of
inappropriate antibiotic therapy and you
see we have analyzed the administered
inappropriate antibiotic therapy and the
prescribed
uh inappropriate antibiotic therapy so
that's what you see on the left hand
side and the right hand side
and indeed the use of the universal pcr
panel could
decrease the use of inappropriate
antibiotic therapy from
86 hours in the control group to 47
hours in the pcr group which is highly
significant
this means it's a reduction of the
inappropriate antibiotic therapy by
almost 50
and the whole duration of the antibiotic
therapy could reduce by 1 4. so i think
really quite significant results a very
low p-value suggesting that this effect
is quite robust
then we also looked at freedom from
inappropriate antibiotic therapy and i
must share that we have as a predefined
condition for um definition for
inappropriate antibiotic therapy which
also include the fact that the therapy
should be for at a
maximum of seven days after the bal so
if somebody has been treated more than
longer than seven days with an
antibiotic it was considered to be
inappropriate because it's too long so
in this chart you only see what is
happening in the first seven days after
that everybody would have an
inappropriate antibiotic therapy based
on predefined criteria and analyzed by a
committee that included someone from
internal medicine uh someone from
infectious diseases uh and some
anaphylamologists
but you see here what happened in the
first seven days and you see the freedom
from antibiotic therapy which was
significantly higher uh in the group
that have been
examined by the universal pcr panel
indeed the probability of being
free from inappropriate antibiotic
therapy was three times higher in the
patient group that was examined with the
pcr
and here i must say also to make sure
that okay we are decreasing the amount
of antibiotics we are
using less broad spectrum antibiotics
here so really more appropriate
antibiotic therapy less inappropriate
but
at the cost that the patients are having
a poor outcome this is not the case so
we look very carefully at several
criteria
looking for example at the time to
clinical stability that has been
evaluated daily and you see
a very very similar curve here so we had
91
or 92 percent of the patients reaching
clinical stability of being discharged
over time the time to clinical stability
or this child's discharge was exactly
the same in both groups
uh also the length of hospital stay was
the same
intensive care admission was the same
and the mortality at 30 days was
also the same for our group so it's it's
not only that you are decreasing the
antibiotics you are giving appropriate
antibiotics instead of inappropriate but
you are doing this without any costs the
safety of this approach
seem to be
quite good as demonstrated by this
data
if we look at the diagnostic performance
we found bacterial agents in around one
a fifth of the patients
even if we look with molecular
diagnostics it's not that easy confirmed
by this study
we found more grand negative
roads in um
in the bal using the pcr
as compared to culture as expected and
the sensitivity and specificity as
compared to the conventional
microbiology was around 56 and 87
percent again we already discussed uh
that these uh figures are uh difficult
because of the lack of a real gold
standard
so i think based on the data we've
discussed today uh i think we can say
that if you incorporate uh results of
the universe panel so a multiplex
bacterial pcr of the broncho of vel
lavage into an antibiotic stewardship
approach that should be going on
everywhere anyway
it makes sense it is efficient it's safe
and it really decreases time on
inappropriate antibiotic therapy
particularly if we look at the
population we examine here hospitalized
patients with
pneumonia
at risk for negative roads
and
for sure there are other questions that
have to be addressed in the future
the cost of this
of this approach i believe we will
reduce significantly the costs because
patients will receive less antibiotics
have less side effects and probably go
home earlier but we will need larger
studies to confirm to confirm this this
findings
so
take home messages i would say that the
main advantage of a bacteriomorphic pcr
relies in its
speed i mean it's a fast examination you
have results very early and you were
able to adapt antibiotic therapy very
early
it has a higher sensitivity than
conventional methods
if we talk about the universal if we
look about
specif specifically if we focus on run
negative roads i think we can say that
and
we do not have any
data support in the use of this
technology alone we cannot
refrain from performing conventional
microbiology
and we cannot also not say that we do
not need antibiotic stewardship it's
very important but if we combine
antibiotic stewardship with the pcr
results then we have a clear gain for
our patients we can reduce the the
duration of inappropriate antibiotic
therapy and i think this might have
major consequences for patients and
institutions
so with that i will stop here uh thank
you for your attention and i'll be very
happy to take your questions and discuss
uh how do you see the results how you
can apply this technology to your
clinical work thank you very much
thank you professor stoltz for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
which gram negative bras were most
prevalent in your study
yes so thank you for the question and i
think it's an important information that
i didn't share with you uh but i think
the the ones we seen most commonly were
are the ones that we expected
pseudomonas aeruginosa and hemophilus in
frenzy i must say
switzerland especially the north of
switzerland is
blessed by have been very restrictive
with the use of broad spectrum
antibiotics we do not have
highly resistant
negative roads
in our icus so far
so we
we don't see things like we used to say
to see in the u.s with really a lot of
very resistant glue negative bacteria
but we do see the same spectrum of
bacteria in our care here
thank you professor stoltz the next
question is based on the impact that
univero made which were reduction in the
use of inappropriate antibiotic therapy
by 45.1 percent
shortened inappropriate antibiotic
therapy by 39 hours and three times
higher probability of avoiding
inappropriate antibiotic therapy etc
what is the cost savings impact
yeah that's a good question um
the study didn't focus on
the
costs
or the cost savings that this technology
created but i think it's a sensible
question to ask
i believe there are two different
important parts of the information here
the one is how much money we can save
really within one hospitalization by
decreasing the exposure to antibiotics
and probably side effects
the other one is also the impact that it
has in a broader view
meaning you know what happens to the
development of resistance within a
hospital as such
so um i think that's an important
question to explore i cannot offer you
an answer right now but i'm sure um it
makes sense to to go after that and i'm
sure that the benefits won't be only
financial for one particular patient but
we will also transfer into savings for
an institution
thank you professor stoltz i'd like to
remind the audience that if you would
like to ask a question please do so now
click on the ask a question box and then
type in your question click send
we have one more question in the queue
here is the univaro system easy to use
was it run in the lab or was it run by
the medical staff during your study
yeah well we organized the the study in
a way that we had the universe system
located next to the bronchoscopy suite
it's it's quite a small system so you
find place almost everywhere to place it
and it's actually quite easy to use
the test was performed by our endoscopy
staff so immediately after finishing the
bronchovirus lavage and sending the
patient back to the station
they prepared the probe
for testing
and the bronchovirus fluid has been
placed in the machine
it's really quite intuitive and after
pro appropriate training i think
everybody is able to um to deal with it
um i think it has a potential to be a
point of care test
and it saves for short time i think it's
also interesting that we've seen that
for a proportion of patients
physicians were aware that they would
get the result within four hours so they
kind of waited to get the result of the
pcr to start until epic therapy because
they thought okay four hours it's a
time span that it's okay to wait i can
for sure not wait one or two days but
four hours it's okay so we've seen a lot
of patients that start receiving
appropriate antibiotic therapy to begin
with
and i think this time aspect is quite
important
because it really decreases
the exposure to the wrong drugs it's
much more difficult in the hospital to
change a therapy that has been already
established than to
start to begin with with the right
therapy
thank you again professor stoltz looks
like we have no other questions in the
queue do you have any final comments for
our audience before we go
well i think this is an extremely
interesting
field to explore and
i i advise everyone that is involved in
the treatment of patients with severe
pulmonary disease to consider this
technology
as
we really have to care about um
decreasing antibiotic resistance and
making sure that we are treating the
right patient with the right drug um it
has been a major development for our
hospital we do have a lot of
stem cell transplant patients so we're
very happy to count on
a very fast test that is reliable and
help us to treat patients in a better
way
thank you again professor diana stoltz
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor opjen
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye